[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend noch ist es viel zu früh
niemand weiß wie lange die das so
durchhalten aber bisher haben es die
kleinen delegationen von rot gelb grün
geschafft ohne schweiß oder wutausbrüche
und ohne erschöpfungs strategien
sachlich miteinander zu verhandeln über
notwendige gemeinsamkeiten gemeinsame
notwendigkeiten und das was ihr auch
noch trend für unsere berufsgruppe ist
es ein bisschen ärgerlich aber ein
bisschen muss man so auch bewundern da
kommt nicht mehr raus als das was die
offiziellen offiziell hinterher und voll
öffentlich als zwischenstand verkünden
heute geschah das besonders früh weil
einer der da eine gewisse rolle spielt
in alter funktion noch eine dienstreise
antreten musste darauf nimmt man
rücksicht andreas künast verfolgt von
uns was es da zu verfolgen gibt
als der bundesfinanzminister
kanzlerkandidat und
spd-verhandlungsführer am nachmittag in
den regierungs-airbus steigt ist merkels
stammplatz zum draufsetzen nach scholz'
fliegt zum treffen der
g-20-finanzminister und ist dem
kanzlersessel in den stunden zuvor ein
gutes stück näher gekommen
die menge an gemeinsamkeiten ist größer
geworden
die mega in unterschieden ist kleiner
geworden aber es bleiben auch noch
sachen zu lösen zu klären die nachricht
am tag zwei der sogenannten vertieften
sondierungen ist dass es keine nachricht
gibt kein abbruch kein ausbruch kein
bekannt gewordener vertrauensbruch das
bisschen das haus dringt aus dem
verhandlungsraum klingt vorsichtig
optimistisch die zehn wichtigsten themen
wollten spd grüne und fdp durchgehend
die letzten drei waren heute dran es
ging um europa verrät ministerpräsident
kretschmann um flucht und migration das
dritte
es müssen bereits sehr scharfkantige
gespräche sein denn es geht nicht um die
einfachen es geht um die schwierigen
punkte
wissen dass die entfernung zwischen drei
parteien vielleicht am größten sind also
wir müssen nicht über kleinigkeiten
reden oder nettigkeiten austauschen
sondern es geht gerade darum um die
dinge zu sprechen von denen wir wissen
dass sie am ende wirklich große punkte
sind die zwischen unseren drei parteien
geklärt werden soll aus jeweils sechs
mitgliedern besteht ein sondierungsteam
plus jeweils einen notizen schreiber
zuerst war die mission sich zu verstehen
jetzt ob alle dasselbe verstanden haben
bis freitag wollen die drei
generalsekretäre auf maximal acht seiten
zusammen schreiben auf was sich rot grün
und gelb im großen und ganzen einigen
könnten höflich und sachorientiert
miteinander zu sprechen ist das eine das
gesagte schriftliche auszuformulieren
ist dagegen die stunde der wahrheit es
gibt welche die wenigstens ein klein
bisschen was zum stand der einigung
sagen
es gibt welche die wenigstens ein wort
und es gibt einen der nichts überhaupt
gar nichts sagt der mann der den
kanzlersessel heute abend ein bisschen
näher ist als heute früh
der nachrichten tag brachte heute auch
eine drastische erinnerung daran dass
die probleme da draußen nicht kleiner
werden während deutschland damit
beschäftigt ist sich eine regierung
zusammen zu puzzeln die mächtigen der
g20 der gruppe der größten
industrienationen in clou including die
sage das inklusive eu plus un trafen
sich virtuell zur lage in afghanistan
ihr vorsitzender italiens mario draghi
hat auf dem sondergipfel bestanden zum
teil haben die figuren dort in der
region gegensätzliche interessen aber
ein gemeinsames problem die lage der
menschen dort im heraufziehenden winter
zwinge die welt zum handeln
das wird nicht einfach die taliban sind
keine partner denen man trauen kann oder
mit denen man freiwillig
zusammenarbeiten wollte und trotzdem
geht für die deutsche regierung eines
nicht zuzuschauen wie 40 millionen
menschen ins chaos verfallen weil weder
strom geliefert werden kann noch ein
finanzsystemen existiert das kann und
darf nicht das ziel der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft sein
wie prekär die situation der menschen
selbst in der hauptstadt kabul jetzt
schon ist berichtet katrin eigendorf
die männer dieser dem morgengrauen am
rande der straße stehen haben nur eine
hoffnung heute nicht mit leeren händen
nach hause zurückkehren einen job zu
finden wenigstens für einen tag auch
verriet kann man gar ist mit 48 jahren
zum tagelöhner geworden früher ein
büroangestellter
es ist jetzt schon spät nach 7 uhr 30
wird es schwierig einen job zu kriegen
hier gibt es leute die seit einem monat
keine arbeit mehr finden konnten seitdem
die radikalislamischen taliban die macht
übernommen haben 6 die note fast täglich
und darunter leiden vor allem die kinder
jeden tag werden es mehr die in den
strassen betteln hunger ist für viele
von ihnen alltag immer mehr leiden unter
unterernährung zehn millionen mädchen
und jungen so schätzt das
kinderhilfswerk der vereinten nationen
sind bereits jetzt auf humanitäre hilfe
angewiesen
farid kann man gar versucht seine drei
kinder zu beschützen doch wie lange wird
er das noch schaffen noch haben sie eine
wohnung doch essensvorräte haben sie
nicht mehr es gibt nur brot und tee
zucker
niemand gibt ihr einen kredit den banken
geht es schlecht es gibt kein einkommen
das ist eine harte situation
ich bin bereit einen teil meines körpers
zu verkaufen zum beispiel eine niere um
meine familie wenigstens eine zeit lang
zu ernähren
seitdem die taliban die macht übernommen
haben hat sich für die familie alles
verändert verriet hat seinen job
verloren und die 16-jährigen er ab muss
zu hause bleiben weil die taliban die
schule für mädchen geschlossen haben was
aus der dreijährigen wird für mädchen
sind die zukunftsaussichten in
afghanistan besonders besorgniserregend
mein vater hat alles versucht dass wir
eine gute ausbildung für die zukunft in
unserem land bekommen jetzt ist die
situation sehr hart mein vater und meine
mutter können nichts mehr für uns tun so
hoffnungslos sehen viele menschen die
lage in ihrem land mitten in kabul
verkaufen sie ihr hab und gut für viele
der einzige weg noch über die runden zu
kommen doch in den kalten wintermonaten
droht die lage schlimmer zu werden
internationale hilfe dringend notwendig
doch ob und wie internationale
organisationen in afghanistan künftig
arbeiten können wird maßgeblich von den
taliban abhängen ihren sicherheits zu
sagen verriet kann man gar zieht auch am
nächsten morgen wieder los mit seinem
fahrrad ins zentrum von kabul irgendwie
überleben das ist alltag eines
familienvaters in afghanistan
andreas postel ist für uns in rom wo der
virtuelle g20-gipfel zu diesem thema
heute seinen realen mittelpunkt hatte
andreas was ist an hilfszusagen
herausgekommen
die g20 waren wenn auch virtuell heute
sichtlich bemüht den scherbenhaufen
zusammenzukehren
und dabei mitzuhelfen dass das
versorgungs das wirtschaftssystem in
afghanistan nicht zusammenbricht im
wesentlichen kann man sagen dass das
zustandekommen dieses gipfels heute
allein für den vorsitzenden g20 für
mario draghi schon als erfolg zu werten
ist es gab wesentlich drei motivation
dafür erstens die hilfe zu organisieren
zu organisieren zweitens die
flüchtlingsströme in größerem maße
gerade aus europäischer perspektive zu
vermeiden und drittens den kampf gegen
den terrorismus zu organisieren das
alles sind wesentliche punkte und man
hat sich heute vollständig darauf dass
die vereinten nationen die koordinierung
der hilfsgüter übernehmen sollen dass
sie das mandat bekommen von den g20 man
hat sich dafür eingesetzt dass das geld
auch an die nachbarländer fließen kann
damit flüchtlinge vor ort geholfen
werden kann und auch als sie im land
gehalten werden und der region gehalten
werden können und man hat an die taliban
regierung appelliert dass die flughäfen
offen gehalten werden damit hilfsgüter
eingeflogen werden können und
schutzbedürftige außer landes geflogen
werden können außerdem hat man an die
taliban regierung deutlich appelliert
dass die menschenrechte die frauenrechte
eingehalten werden sollen mein appell
ist das eine die zu sagen das andere und
die hat man noch nicht so richtig die
taliban sind nicht die einzigen
schwierigen partner auch die staaten die
da auf unserer tafel hier vorhin
zusammenkam haben in afghanistan ja
völlig verschiedene interessen china
russland europa wie soll das jetzt in
einer zusammenarbeit aufgehen
das ist schon im ansatz kompliziert
wurde auch heute deutlich denn die runde
hat sich darauf verständigt dass eine
eine anerkennung der taliban regierung
gar nicht auf der tagesordnung stand so
weit ich weiß hat man sich darüber heute
nicht unterhalten und wenn man auf die
tafel cook die virtuelle dann fiel auf
dass heute zwei wesentliche player in
diesem spiel gar nicht am tisch saßen
und zwar der russische präsident und der
präsident der chinesischen volksrepublik
ließen sich vertreten
dabei ist aus geostrategischer sicht
sicherlich ganz besonders wichtig wie
sich die beiden der taliban regierung
gegenüber verhalten insofern ist der
g-20 sonder gibt für die heute
sicherlich ein starkes signal dass die
internationale staatengemeinschaft
afghanistan im blick behält aber die
blick der blickwinkel wie viele
zugeständnisse mann der
taliban-regierung machen wird der ist
doch sehr unterschiedlich und insofern
kann man nur hoffen dass jetzt die hilfe
die wir heute in rom verabschiedet
worden ist bei den menschen auch ganz
schnell ankommt zu schauen so hat es
auch die kanzlerin gesagt ist ja keine
option dankeschön andreas morgen werden
wir hier darüber berichten wie
deutschland den einsatz der bundeswehr
in afghanistan
würdigt nach einigem hin und her gibt es
ja jetzt ein solches bekenntnis zu
dieser mission und zu ihrem ausgang die
deutschen truppen waren aus afghanistan
ja schon weg als der kollaps der
afghanischen armee einen letzten einsatz
nötig machte die bundeswehr die
luftwaffe musste zurück an den
hindukusch das wurde so weit er ging ein
erfolgreicher einsatz tausende die um
ihr leben fürchteten wurden damals
ausgeflogen es gab auch keine verluste
unter den deutschen soldatinnen und
soldaten und trotzdem spürt man in den
aussagen von general art dem
verantwortlichen offizier was dieser
einsatz von allen gefordert hat susanne
freitag berichtet
bewaffneter general umarmt
verteidigungsministerin die geste so
ungewöhnlich wie der einsatz selbst eine
hochdynamische einsatz mit nichts zu
vergleichen was sie bis dato erlebt habe
wo jeder an seine belastungsgrenze geht
und jeder sich einbringt um das ganze
möglich zu machen brigadegeneral lienz
alt ist stolz auf seine truppe doch wie
sehr die tage in kabul sie alle
erschüttert haben merkte man hier bei
seinem ersten pressegespräch in saloon
er redet fast eine stunde ohne pause
erzählt wie sie ihn am 14 august bei
einer familienfeier anriefen von dort
ging es direkt nach kabul
die kommen rein und in dem moment wenn
sie dann haben sie eingangs hohen pegeln
er bleibt konstant auf dem sie kommen
nicht mehr runter der druck wird immer
höher
tausende verzweifelte menschen gefechte
verletzte tote wer aus afghanistan raus
wollte musste in den flughafen rhein
über barrieren mit stacheldraht es trat
wie die soldaten sagen die die menschen
hier raus bringen sollten wenn sie
bilder sehen dass frauen einfach
niedergewalzt werden und kinder
die wirklichen in es trat eingetreten
werden die dann in extra drin hängen und
die sie dort wieder rausschneiden also
das ist das portal das ist einfach
unmenschlich
manchmal waren bis zu 6000 menschen
gleichzeitig im flughafen
das abwasser wird nicht entsorgt sie es
kommt also dazu dass sie natürlich dann
überall auch experiment haben also es
ist ein wachsendes stinkt zum himmel
und in dieser situation leben sie und
das kein stück besser egal
in der situation die verändert sich von
tag zu tag die wird nicht besser
moralischer ausnahmezustand mehrere
tausend mal mussten die soldaten
entscheiden wer in die flieger der
hoffnung durfte und wer nicht
traumatisch für alle ich hab das auch
den männer und frauen gesagt also macht
euch ja keine illusionen gibt euch keine
illusionen neuer kommandeur gaben also
wenn sie familienvater sind und sie
sehen einfach wie mit kindern umgegangen
wird und frauen das lässt sinnlichkeit
ja und dass das ist auch wichtig also
wenn ich glaube einfach im ganz
entscheidend ist dass man mensch bleibt
in so einer situation bei all der
brutalität und barbarei die man da
draußen sieht
militärisch war die evakuierung in kabul
ein erfolg der jahrzehntelange
afghanistan-einsatz aber vergeblich auch
jetzt hat in afghanistan gekämpft und
musste das land nun den taliban
überlassen ein desaster alt warnt davor
die soldaten zu vergessen die noch heute
unter posttraumatischen
belastungsstörungen leiden man darf die
veteranen und auch die kamera die auch
vielleicht belasteten ptbs nicht außen
vor lassen
daher das gilt es auch in einklang zu
bringen also sind wir sind nicht besser
wir sind haben nur andere sachen erlebt
andere sachen gemacht in der kurzen
phase
das bundesverdienstkreuz und die anderen
auszeichnungen hat jens a und auch
stellvertretend für die soldatinnen und
soldaten entgegen genommen der einsatz
in afghanistan lässt noch viele fragen
offen die aufarbeitung hat gerade erst
begonnen und
nachrichten nun von gundula gause die eu
will ihre politischen und
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen zur ukraine
vertiefen auch die energiesicherheit des
landes war thema eines gipfeltreffens in
kiew von eu-kommissionspräsident in von
der leyen und raths chef michelle mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten sie lenski
seit 2005 10 bcf kein erdgas mehr direkt
aus russland
hintergrund ist der dauerkonflikt in der
ost ukraine die lenski machte russland
dafür verantwortlich dass ein geplantes
friedensabkommen nicht vorankommt einer
frage nach dem eu-beitritt tiefs wie ich
von der leyen aus vor der
präsidentschaftswahl in frankreich im
nächsten april hat präsident makro einen
30 milliarden euro schweren plan zur
modernisierung des landes vorgestellt
der staat werde in die auto raum und
luftfahrt branche investieren um
frankreich wieder zu einem
innovationsland zu machen sagte makro
vor konzernchefs und studierenden dabei
kündigte er auch investitionen in die
atomindustrie an diese sei ein glück für
das land vor allem kleine atomkraftwerke
und neue technologien zur verarbeitung
von atommüll will makro fördern wenn er
wiedergewählt wird
großbritannien hat fast
138.000 corona tote zu beklagen ein
untersuchungsbericht des parlaments
macht die politik von regierungschef
johnson dafür mitverantwortlich dass
herauszögern eines lockdown zu beginn
der pandemie sei eines der größten
versäumnisse im bereich der öffentlichen
gesundheit in der geschichte des landes
johnsons regierung habe das virus
anfangs unterschätzt und die
grenzkontrollen zu spät für erst das
alles habe menschenleben gekostet
die lage auf der kanaren insel la palma
hat sich wegen des anhaltenden
vulkanausbruchs wieder verschärft die
behörden ordneten weitere große
evakuierungen an etwa 800 menschen sind
aktuell aufgefordert wegen der näher
rückenden lavaströme ihre häuser zu
verlassen
seit dem ausbruch des vulkans vor gut
drei wochen sind mehr als 1000 anwesen
zerstört worden in den vergangenen tagen
hatte der ausbruch an intensität wieder
zugelegt
in deutschland verhandelt das
bundesverfassungsgericht seit heute eine
ungewöhnliche sache politische parteien
wehren sich dagegen mehr geld vom staat
zu bekommen grüne linkspartei und fdp
plus etwas anders aufgezogen die afd
halten für verfassungswidrig was spd und
union vor drei jahren mal schnell durch
den bundestag gebracht hatten eine
deftige erhöhung der staatlichen
zuschüsse an politische parteien
das verfassungsgericht muss jetzt wieder
weitergehen auf einem schmalen grat
zwischen einem system in dem die
parteien vom staat abhängig werden oder
einem system in dem sie von privaten
geldgebern abhängig sind dafür sind die
usa ein wann das beispiel einen
selbstbedienungsladen in den parteien
nimmersatt per gesetz immer großzügigere
zuschüsse abzapfen kann aber auch
niemand wollen sarah tacke und christoph
schneider über eine teure balance
hier zeigt die junge union bayern in
einem werbefilm wie sie für ihre partei
arbeitet infozettel rucksäcke und auch
so ein werbefilm produzieren all das
kostet geld viel geld das die parteien
von ihren mitgliedern und privatpersonen
bekommen aber eben auch vom staat wie
viel zuschuss eine partei vom staat
bekommt richtet sich zum einen nach den
wahlergebnissen zum anderen nach den
mitgliedsbeiträgen und auch die spenden
von privatpersonen werden bis zu einer
höhe von 3300 euro berücksichtigt je
mehr also mitglieder und spender der
partei überweisen desto mehr gibt der
staat auch dazu alle parteien durften
zusammen bisher mit maximal 165
millionen euro bezuschusst werden bei
dieser abstimmung 2018 hob die große
koalition die obergrenze dann um 25 auf
aktuell 190 millionen euro an fdp linke
und grüne finden das falsch es gab ein
verfahren bei dem schläger greift nicht
hinreichend dargelegt wurde warum diese
erhöhung nötig ist wieso jetzt auf
einmal dieser hohen geldbedarf nötig ist
da hat das bundesverfassungsgericht enge
grenzen gezogen zu recht um eben zu
verhindern dass der eindruck entsteht
die politiker würden sich hier einfach
selbst bedienen keine selbstbedienung
sondern zwingend notwendig sei die
erhöhung so die verteidigung die
digitalisierung hat dazu geführt dass
die parteien enorme aufwendungen tätigen
müssen um die sozialen medien zu
bespielen sie müssen sich schützen gegen
hacker angriffe und sie müssen permanent
reagieren auf die diskussion die im
internet stattfinden und das kostet sehr
viel geld weil gleichzeitig auch noch
ältere parteimitglieder mit den
herkömmlichen mitteln angesprochen
werden müssen und die parteien können
ihre grundgesetzlichen aufgabe nur
erfüllen wenn sie mehr geld dafür
erhalten mehr geld gab es für die
parteien immer wieder die beträge die
der staat den parteien überwies stiegen
in den vergangenen zehn jahren um etwa
50 prozent
zuletzt waren als die erlaubten 190
millionen euro plus inflationsausgleich
also 197 millionen euro im jahr bei der
letzte zuschlag einer zu viel ab wann
geriet die balance zwischen staatlicher
unterstützung und privaten geldern aus
dem gleichgewicht wann ist die
unabhängigkeit gefährdet das entscheiden
sie die richterinnen und richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht
um gemäß der korona vorschriften
verhandeln zu können sind sie in diese
messe halle umgezogen zwei tage nehmen
sie sich zum klären deckten fliegen
fragen
bei der staatlichen parteienfinanzierung
handelt es sich um einen politisch und
verfassungsrechtlich
sensiblen bereich der für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserer durch
die parteien geprägten demokratie von
erheblichem interesse ist wie dieser
sensible bereich parteienfinanzierung
auszugestalten ist das verkünden die
richterinnen und richter in einigen
monaten
die weltwirtschaft wird sich in diesem
jahr gut von der korona pandemie erholen
trotz hoher inflation und weltweiter
lieferprobleme so sieht es der
internationale währungsfonds in seiner
aktuellen prognose die auf der
herbsttagung in washington diskutiert
wird frank bethmann welche perspektiven
beschreibt der iwf den für deutschland
ja die lieferengpässe seien besonders
für deutschland ein problem die
fehlenden vorprodukte die halbleiter
bremsten das wachstum die heimische
wirtschaft könnte ansonsten stärker
zulegen die konjunkturerholung insgesamt
aber hält an für deutschland erwartet
der iwf nun ein leicht nach unten
korrigiertes wachstum von 3,1 prozent in
diesem dann aber eines von 4,6 prozent
im kommenden jahr deutschland damit im
trend überall wo die impfquote hoch ist
in den industrieländern ist auch das
wachstum stark in den schwellen- und
entwicklungsländern das gegenteilige
bild sprache impfquote stagnierendes
wachstum
die pandemie hat die weltwirtschaft also
gespalten wo das virus nicht ausreichend
bekämpft werden kann zeigen sich
bremsspuren in den reicheren ländern
dagegen kämpft man bereits mit dem
nächsten problem mit der inflation über
das gesamtjahr rechnet der iwf damit
dass die verbraucherpreise in
deutschland bis zu vier prozent steigen
doch schon im kommenden jahr entwarnung
dann soll die preissteigerung nur noch
bei 1,5 prozent liegen allerdings ist
nichts in stein gemeißelte ausbildung
sei mit erheblichen unsicherheiten vor
da die weltweiten risiken insgesamt
zugenommen hätten so der iwf heute von
bethmann vielen dank
eine der bedeutendsten fotografinnen
deutschlands evelyn richter ist im alter
von 91 jahren in dresden gestorben sie
galt als chronistin der lebens- und
arbeitswelten in der ddr mehr als 730
fotografien sind im museum der bildenden
künste in leipzig zu sehen darunter
bilder die stresstests und verfall
zeigen
früher als geplant hat die lufthansa
einen teil der staatlichen krone hilfen
zurückgezahlt die airline überwies 15
milliarden euro an den wirtschafts
stabilitätsfonds möglich wurde die
rückzahlung durch die ausgabe neuer
lufthansa-aktien die airline hatte in
der korona krise mit bundesregierung und
eu-kommission ein insgesamt neun
milliarden euro schweres rettungspaket
ausgehandelt laut konzernchef spur
konnten so etwa 100.000 arbeitsplätze
gesichert werden
eine ausstellung der kunsthalle mannheim
widmet sich mit haut und haar einer
gestalt ohne die kein mensch jemals
geboren worden wäre aus der universalen
verkörperung von anfang fächert sich die
schau auf in verherrlichung und abgrund
in umarmung und ablehnung liebe bis in
alle denkbaren varianten und einige
schon aus der zu fast saniert findet
anna wassberg
eine alles liebende alles verzeihende
aufopferungsvolle mutter die madonna
überzeichnete ikonenhafte darstellung
einer mutter die die westliche kunst
prägt bis heute die kunsthalle mannheim
stellt jetzt aus was ausnahmslos jede
und jeden betrifft etwas was wir
gemeinsam haben etwas wo wir vielleicht
den gleichen ausgangspunkt haben aber
danach selbstständig auch
unterschiedlich darauf zurückblicken
können weil ich ja nicht jeder die über
mutterschaft die sie nicht vielleicht
teilen da haben sie andere erfahrungen
als ich gemacht vielleicht haben sie
auch bittere erfahrung aber den
grundzustand der ist doch gleich die
ausstellung mutter ausrufezeichen will
den besucherinnen und besuchern ganz
unterschiedliche zugänge zu diesem sehr
persönlichen und komplexen thema
ermöglichen mit alten meistern genauso
wie mit zeitgenössischer kunst
[Musik]
weg vom idealisierten mutterbild führt
diese begehbare rauminstallation der
künstlerin lore wo sie ist selbst gerade
mutter geworden
beängstigend und gleichzeitig schützen
breitet das kraken ähnliche muttertier
hier seine fangarme aus und nähert aus
unzähligen gläsernen brüsten die mutter
als sonderbares wesen dessen bild sich
permanent verändert es gibt sehr viele
positionen in dieser ausstellung die
insofern sehr interessant ist weil hier
viele künstlerinnen ihre haltung zur
mutterschaft oder ihr blick auf mutter
sein und auf mutter bilder zu sehen sind
was bedeutet es eigentlich mutter zu
sein wenn ich künstlerin bin oder wie
reagiere ich auf das was ich vielleicht
auch an schwierigkeiten mit meiner
eigenen mutter hatte
was kann mütterliche fürsorge noch sein
in einer diversen modernen gesellschaft
in der klassische rollenbilder
aufgebrochen werden eine frage mit der
sich immer mehr künstlerinnen und
künstler auseinandersetzen kann so sagen
mutterschaft ist für alle wichtig aber
vielleicht gar nicht mehr nur biologisch
gesehen sondern eine soziale
gesellschaftliche funktion die damit
vielleicht sogar noch wichtiger wird als
sie rein biologisch gesehen wurde es
geht hier auch um das nicht muttersein
selbstportraits der finnischen
fotografen elina brutt russ zeigen ihren
weg und den misslungenen versuch einer
künstlichen befruchtung und am ende das
bild mit dem provokanten titel mein hund
ist süßer als dein hässliches baby eine
ausstellung die keine klischees bedient
sondern zeigt wie sich das bild der
mutterschaft über die zeit radikal
verändert hat
in der kunsthalle mannheim 37 grad kommt
gleich mit einer reportage über einen
jungen mann ist ohne arme und beine zur
welt gekommen und er schafft es mit
seinen freunden auf den kilimandscharo
zu steigen ein traum eine extreme
geschichte von freundschaft und
vielleicht schenkt sie ja kraft wenn ihn
weniger extremen leben ein berg vor
einem steht und
um mitternacht ist hier wieder zeit für
unser heute-journal update mit dem sich
dann anna maria chocolate bis 9
[Musik]
guten abend schön also der starke fall
wind auf der wetter abgewandten seite
von gebirgen gibt es nicht nur im
erzgebirge in der eifel in den alpen
sondern auch südlich des norwegischen
gebirges dieser skandinavien führen
brachte heute dem süden norwegens dem
süden schwedens aber auch dänemark und
norddeutschland viel sonnenschein zum
beispiel st peter ording aber auch in
hamburg magdeburg und später in berlin
in der mitte und im süden waren die
wolken dagegen dichter und mit dem hoch
das westlich von uns liegt hat das
eigentlich nur ganz wenig zu tun aber
sie sehen dieses hoch ist dreh und
angelpunkt des wetters die tiefs müssen
draußen rom ziehen und dieses tief hier
das bringt auch wieder neuen regen
richtung norwegen und auch da wird es
hinter dem norwegischen gebirge wieder
abreißen mit den wolken einige kommen
allerdings bei uns an heute nach fällt
noch regen hier am alpenrand sonst wird
das morgen aber ein freundlicher tag und
dann kommen diese neuen regenwolken
morgen in der nacht hier von nordwesten
her ab heute nacht also müssen sie sich
an den alpen noch oberhalb von 1000
meter auf schnee einstellen sonst gibt
es wenige schauer und in norddeutschland
ist ist klar dort wird es kalt die
temperaturen sinken zum teil nahe 0 grad
es gibt also örtlich bodenfrost im
westen bleibt die nacht milder und die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 6 grad an den alpen und 14 grad
am niederrhein und das wird ein ganz
freundlicher tag mit etwas schnee an den
alpen und am donnerstag regnet es am
ehesten im osten am freitag am ehesten
im norden und am samstag er gar nicht
kennt